so Aquaman and the lost kingdom had its
first trailer shown at audiences at
Cinema con and throughout this video
we're going to be breaking down what
happens in the footage bouncing off the
back of a billion dollar Blockbuster the
sequels sailing the Seven Seas during a
time in which comic book movies are no
longer kicking up a storm when it comes
to the box office Shazam 2 bombed and
with James good announcing a soft reboot
in the DCU a lot of things are up in the
air that includes Jason Momoa who is
rumored to be playing Lobo in the
universe going forward whether that
happens or not we'll have to see but I
do think there's a number of things that
could kill the buzz about this film in
this video though we're going to be
trying to maintain the hype and go
through it all and if you enjoy it then
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for breakdowns
like this every day by the way a huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into Aquaman and the lost kingdom
now according to the wrap the trailer
opens with authorizing his child
alongside his father Tom Curry leaks
around the film said that Mira would be
revealed to have given birth at some
point and that they'll be bringing up a
little Aqualad in regards to Amber Heard
they did say that she appeared in the
trailer briefly as her and there has
been a shot of her released in her armor
obviously this is coming off the back of
her defamation lawsuit with Johnny Depp
and the petition to have her removed
from the movie at this point I'm kind of
just keeping my nose out of stuff and
everyone's asking me all the time why I
haven't made videos on Jonathan majors
and Ezra Miller I just don't know if
it's the kind of place that the heavy
spoilers channel should be and I did get
a lot of backlash from covering the
trial so yeah I don't think those kind
of videos are a good fit for the channel
I know with the whole Jonathan Mages
thing that a lot of people have been
like why is this guy getting fired when
Ezra Miller hasn't but as of making this
video none of these people have actually
been fired and I think it's because they
all have finished projects like this
studios are probably gonna see what the
reception dimilla Mages and Loki season
2 and amberhead and this is before they
start to get rid of anyone
look I said I wasn't gonna talk about it
and we've derailed the entire thing
already
sake let's get back to the trailer
anyway according to AV club we're very
much getting the idea that Arthur's
taking on his responsibilities as a
father and he's also learning from both
of his parents how best to handle this
situation that's where Nicole Kidman's
Outlander comes in and the footage is
meant to show her riding on the back of
a seahorse now this isn't just any
seahorse and it's a seahorse with a
freaking laser strapped to its head
They're bringing back the big underwater
battles from the first film and we'll
watch issue blasts away whilst riding on
the back of it on the opposite side of
this we have Black Manta returning and
he'll now apparently be wielding a giant
black Trident I'm guessing that this
will be the super weapon of the movie
which will probably have incredible
power that's laced within it apparently
we see a green glow emanating from it at
one point and this wraps Manta up in its
light Joe Blow theorized that this may
be an evil energy that's capable of
destroying the world and in the hand of
manta it could be completely devastating
now Games Radar said that he's looking
to destroy Aquaman's life on both the
surface and under the water and that is
now more than a match for the DC hero so
we have all these ideas coming together
and Aquaman will have to deal with the
fact that he's trying to be a father
whilst also being the king of Atlantis
this Arthur is put on the back foot and
the family affair gets even more
interesting when he has to turn to his
brother for help the trailer apparently
shows a meeting up with all men begging
him to join up with him so that they can
stop the threat that Black Manta poses
for some big fight scenes the two going
toe-to-toe with the villain and at one
point Manta apparently hits Alm right in
the kisser pow at this point Aquaman
says no one hits my brother but me and
then om responds by saying don't call me
brother it's Oscar winning writing like
that which is why the movie is going to
break the billion and the movie will be
about them putting their differences to
the side we apparently see this
happening in the teaser 2 with all that
one point saying if you lead Atlantis
will follow and there wasn't much
footage shown in the trailer overall and
something like say the flash had had a
far more extensive showcase due to
releasing very shortly Aquaman 2
releases at the end of December and it's
going to be interesting to see if it
capitalizes on the holidays now the
point with Atlanta could actually hint
what happens to her in the movie from
what I could gather she was just
fighting Manta by herself and I'm
guessing this happens early on in the
film to demonstrate his power now
because of this yes shut the [__] up I'm
dropping through time you better shut
the [__] up I'm telling you you shut the
hell up I'm doing a theory time and I'm
saying that Alana will be killed early
on in the film this will be why Arthur
decides to go to his brother for help as
they both have their shed loss om didn't
seem like the kind of guy that would
work with Aquaman but if his mother's
connected to it he would likely do it
for the greater good that's basically
what stopped a lot of things in the
first movie and the pack can end up
coming together over this Shadow loss in
order to avenge her death it would also
set up black man to answer a really big
villain and sign to him destroying
Aquaman's life killing Atlanta would
really add some Stakes to the movie and
yeah personally I think that's the way
gonna go do you do we End Theory time
there
you know now if you want to support the
channel then we've just launched this
brand new black T-shirt plain black with
nothing on it but it's DC inspired all
money helps to go towards videos like
this and it's a limited edition run
meaning that when it's gone it's gone
we've hooked up with a really high
quality manufacturer so that the fabric
is Top Notch and it's also designed to
make you look good by being loose around
your waist and having a better top half
that accentuates your arms and chest
massively appreciate anyone who picks it
up as it supports me Ryan at screen
crush and Greg at real rejects also yeah
I know it's got stuff on it mate I'm
making a joke about them being invisible
you bloody idiot but thanks for buying
and uh well well it's easy and I'm
seeming very confident that you guys are
gonna support and I tell you who else
seems confident DC they are pushing the
flashes being one of the movies of all
time but they have kept things quiet in
the case of Aquaman from what I've heard
the test screenings haven't been that
good and we may end up with another
situation where people just aren't
interested in this film you never know
though and obviously there was a lot of
people who thought the same thing about
Avatar 2 and then look how that turned
out now I think that the flash will be a
good indicator of how this is gonna go
in terms of not only box office but also
with Amber Heard I even think Marvel is
doing this with Mages too and we may
have hit a point where people just don't
care and we'll go and see the movie
anyway even if they don't like who's in
it again don't wanna I don't know way
too far into this but from what Peter
saffron says he is confident that the
movie will be a success Momoa also said
he thinks Aquaman will be involved in
the DCU as well so those Lobo rumors
could be untrue it could also be a case
of them seeing that Shazam 2 bomb pretty
badly and though I don't think that
gun's announcement was the sole reason
it may have been a factor so they're
just kind of playing things like I think
they should have from the start which is
pretend everything's okay not announce
any changes until the current slate is
out and then from there start saying
what you're going to do differently
still baffles me that they announced a
soft reboot coming in when they had
three movies left to release and I think
it just speaks to the mismanagement of
Warner Brothers I'm hoping this in the
flashed as well and now we actually get
a proper unified Vision which it feels
like Gunner is trying to do it's a shame
we've lost some of the actors along the
way and the Cameo for Affleck has now
also been cut from Aquaman too where
things will go we don't know but
obviously let me know your thoughts on
the film and what you think will happen
in it based off this information now we
are in a competition right now giving
away the quantumania steel Buck to three
subscribers on the 15th of May and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the trailer you pick the comments at
random on the 15th and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now say
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our Brighton of the June part 2
trailer which will be linked on screen
right now lots of things to talk about
in that there was a big showcase at
Cinema con 2 so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sticking through the video I've been
poor I'll see you next time take care
peace